um I've had a lot of content taken down
um I for example had an interview with
Robert Kiyosaki taken down from YouTube
because they didn't like what he said
about vaccines and elections when I talk
about Central Bank digital currencies on
Tick Tock that gets taken down
um I think I called Justin Trudeau a
feminist on Tick Tock and that got taken
down so you really just you know you
can't say anything on the internet right
now and it's truly unbelievable and of
course it it causes all sorts of
concerns when it comes to misinformation
because the only way to find out the
truth is to have more and more dialogue
and I know everybody's extremely excited
about Elon Musk now that he's you know
taken over Twitter but I'm not that
excited about it it still concerns me
because it's still you know our right to
free speech and access to free
information is still in the hands of a
of an individual it's an essentialized
entity which is a concern for me and of
course we saw the new CEO she's from the
world economic Forum which creates more
concerns for all of us and I do believe
everybody unfortunately has a price I do
believe that everybody is eventually
corruptable I think the future of the
Creator economy is decentralized and I
know we're going to get into this but
there's so much censorship that we see
online and zooby I know I know you also
for this as well we're almost terrified
of the things that we can and can't say
because
our our content is going to be taken
down and because of course you know we
all have these personal Brands it
becomes your it's your vehicle it's your
way of making money it's your way of
making a living it it becomes like who
you are essentially and when that gets
taken away from you it's extremely
dangerous you know to be canceled is
it's very dangerous it's very difficult
and it's just something that you don't
want it causes a lot of hassle in your
life and so the future of the Creator
economy I would say is completely
decentralized and I also agree in terms
of building a personal brand I think
even when we see media businesses and
well every kind of business that we see
is going to become a media business just
because it's all about putting content
out there it's all about putting a face
to a brand and so everyone is going to
be creating video content more now and
than ever before the mass adoption of
Bitcoin will only happen when people
feel that there's no other option
so a lot of people for example during
2021 when they saw what happened during
the world you know what was going on
with lockdowns and so on a lot of people
just flocked to bitcoin because there
was really no other option and so I
think the same is going to be true again
for social media apps when people just
get censored
um you know people they lose their
livelihood because their business is
essentially shut down by these
corporations they will have to learn
they will have to learn how to use these
decentralized applications and so I
think
adoption comes out of desperation that's
how I see the future going long term I
am extremely concerned about the future
of content creation there's so much that
that I can't say tick tock is is
horrendous Twitter still not very happy
about it people are still getting taken
down on Twitter by the way I had a
friend he uploaded um some content about
uh animal hunting now whether you're Pro
animal hunting or not he got banned from
Twitter this is under Elon Musk uh
Instagram is terrible i've been Shadow
bound on that for a very long time just
because I talk about vaccines I talk
about covid and how to rank all of that
was so you know it it's not great which
is why you know as when I started this I
said that the future of the Creator
economy is 110 decentralized people
don't really want to pay you know like
you can be scrolling through Twitter and
you might see something which entertains
you but doesn't mean you want to pay for
it you know you want to see the drama
you want to see what's going on but you
don't necessarily want to give your
money away people just don't and I
understand now you know people are
paying eight dollars a month for Twitter
but that's because you're giving it to a
company so you feel better about
yourself rather than endorsing somebody
who you don't really like but you know
you like to see the drama and the
entertainment online I think it's as
simple as that people just don't really
want to give their money away to people
that they're not completely invested in
I think in order to give an individual
money you need to be some kind of Super
Fan right and you're not a super fan for
everyone you know there's only probably
a couple people that you absolutely love
and you want to give the money and
that's it so I I think people want to
participate but they don't want to pay